[موسيقى]
الخبير في اي حاجه كان في الاول مجرد واحد
بيبتدي انا عبير الليثي
انا عبير الليثي
حاليا لشركتين
الاولى هي عباره عن
جنسي هي الحمد لله بداناها من
اشتغلت مع اكتر من 15 ملطيناشو
عشان انا اصلا صيدلانيه
وعملنا اكتر من 5000
وخسيس
وزي ما قلت لكم بدانا اخر 2018
الشركه التانيه
اللي فوق سن 30 ان هم يرجعوا يشتغلوا
ويتعلموا ويبقى لهم الفرصه زي اي حد فريش
جراد
دي عبير في 2022
تعالوا كده نشوف عبير كانت ايه قبل كده
انا اتخرجت 2003 من صيدله
الحقيقه لما اتخرجت انا طول عمري واحده
بقى شاطره جدا الاولى على المحافظه مواليد
البحر الاحمر الاولى على المحافظه بجيب
دايما درجات رهيبه ممتازه جدا لما اتخرجت
من صيدله بامتياز مع مرتبه الشرف
صيدليه عادي خالص وده اللي حصل من 2003 ل
2008 في 2008
اشتغلت اعظم مهنه وتفرغتلها هو اني كنت ام
لولدين حمزه وفارس هم زي ما انتم شايفين
هم دلوقتي طول يعني او اطول كمان
ودي كانت اعظم مهنه انا اشتغلتها
وتفرغتلها من 2008 لا 2011 في 2011 انا
تميت 30 سنه
حسيت بقى ان ايه
ايه ده
هو انا هسيب بصمه ولا لا
عبير كانت شاطره قوي
اه بس هي قاعده مع الولاد بس هاي يعني انا
حاسه ان انا ممكن افيد الناس
بجد انا ممكن اعمل حاجات كتير انا ليه ما
عملتش
هو انا انا وحشني اتعلم
هو انا المفروض يعني اتعلم ايه واعمل ايه
وكمان يعني
احنا دلوقتي وانتم في الجامعه بتبصوا كده
على سن 30 انه بعيد شويه
لما بتوصل سنه 30 بتلاقي الدنيا ايه ده هو
انا عملت ايه
هننفذ ايه في وطبعا لما بتعدي الاربعين
نفس الشيء
بيبقى هي مراحل كده
في 2011 لا انا الحق بقى يلا
كنت حاسه نفسي عامله زي التلفزيون ده
كنت حاسه نفسي ان انا هتروح علي والله
خساره انا ممكن اقف على البشريه ودي مش
كلمه يعني عامه انا فعلا ممكن ارفع الناس
انا بجد ممكن اعمل حاجه حلوه
قلت اعمل اي حاجه انا كنت قطعتي وهم كنا
في السعوديه فقلت طب انا هنزل اشتغل
وبدات
عين شمس وخدت ماستر من الازهر
وبدات اشتغل في الماركتينج خدت كميه
اونلاين ماركتينج
رهيبه كنت تقريبا كل شهر باخد لي
حقيقي كنت كل يوم ما بنامش غير تلات اربع
ساعات المهم ان انا لازم اتعلم حاجه جديده
انا عايزه اعوض اللي فاتني بقى انا عايزه
اشوف هعمل ايه
حصل لي
بحمد ربنا عليها
بدات اشتغل في شركات
اشتغلت في مجموعه من الشركات في السعوديه
ما بين ماركتينج ماركت ريسيرش ما بين كنت
بدي دروس كمستري ما بين ان انا اشتغلت
برودكت مانجر في احدى شركات الادويه في
السعوديه الرياض
وبعدين نزلت مصر في 2015 اشتغلت في
الماركتينج
دي حاجه كده بتبقى كلاين سايت بتنمي برضو
شويه سكيلز عندك حلو قوي
خدت دبلومه ماركتينج من الاي يوسي
والحقيقه يعني يعني كانت برضو فارقه جدا
في حياتي الناس اللي تعرفت عليهم هناك
وبطريقه التدريس
بعد ما خلصت الدبلومه حبيت قوي الدجاجه
تعلموا ازاي طب هو سيلفي طب يلا خد كورسات
يمكن ما كان ساعتها مش معروف قوي ان
الفيسبوك نفسه بيدي كورسز هتاخد كورس من
الفيسبوك ومن جوجل ومن اليوتيوب بقيت
عملت
واشتغلت في شركات حلوه قوي واسامي حلوه
قوي وقاز ان انا بيزنس
فانا الحمد لله عملت اسم حلو قوي في السوق
سباشر سوق دوت
زين
في 2018
فقط شغل
وكام عندكم التزامات
كل اللي في يوم وليله ابقى مش معايا وظيفه
وفي اخر الشهر مفيش مرتب
دي حاجه قاتله
تفتكروا عملت ايه
عملت ايه
ما يقوم بيزنس بصراحه ده كان ابعد حاجه
عني
يعني يكون ان انا كنت افتح بيزنس لا لا
انا عايزه اشتغل شغلانه كويسه كنت بقدم
كانت بتجيلي مرتبات يعني مرتباتي كانت
بتبقى عاليه جدا
بس
حصل معي حاجه
برضواني ان انا كنت بزني فانا لازم لما
اجي اسيب شركه لازم ابعت لهم لكل كل
احتراما ان انا ايلاف وسبت الشركه دي
وانتم المفروض يعني
[موسيقى]
وان شاء الله نتقابل بقى في كلمتين حلوين
كده
طيب ايه اللي حصل اللي حصل ان انا جالي
حوالي اكتر من خمس ست اشخاص بيقولوا لي
عبير يلا نفتح شركه انا عايزه اقابلك انت
سبتي شغل تعالي نعمل ده
قعدت مره واتنين وتلاته لدرجه ان انا
اولادي كانوا بيقولوا لي انت مش سايبه
الشغل ايه انت طول النهار بره
الناس كلها
لقيتهم شايفين فيها حاجه
انا مش عارفه هي انا ليه مش شايفاها في
نفسي
ان انا كنت يعني ماشيه من الشغل اللي قبله
متضايقه شويه موجوعه شويه
خدت
قعدت مع نفسي كده قلت هم ليه الناس شايفين
بشكل انا مش قادره اشوفه لنفسي
الصراحه ده كان دور ناس من الان زي ما قلت
لكم
كل خير استاذ مروان فتحي واستاذه ليزا
رحت لهم قلت لهم انا واحد اتنين تلاته
والناس بتقول لي كذا افتحي
هو انا اصلح
قالوا لي ايوه تصلحي بس دي عبير زي ما انت
روحي اسالي الناس
انت لو اشتغلتي وفتحتي شركه الناس هتشتغل
معك ولا لا ده اللي عملته مره واثنين
وثلاثه لقيت قبول قلت خلاص واسامي كبيره
في السوق قلت خلاص هفتح الشركه وفتحت
شركتي ودي كانت
من اجمل الحاجات اللي حصلت لي في 2018 ان
الحمد لله فتحت شركتي بارتنر وطبعا انا
حاطه لكم شويه صور بتحكي لي عن حاجات
كثيره قوي عيشناها مع بعض وكنت اتمنى تبقى
موجوده معانا النهارده رضوى العطار
[تصفيق]
لما تيجي تشارك حد خليه يبقى بتشارك حد
يكملك صفاته غير صفاتك بس بتعرفوا
تتفاهموا
بعد كده بعد ما فتحت الشركه بتاعتي الحمد
لله اشتغلنا حلو قوي
مشينا
جدا اتعاملنا مع شركات كبيره جدا بقى لنا
سمعه حلوه قوي خلال الخمس سنين كنا واصلين
يعني لسمعه كويسه جدا بنطلب بالاسم طلعت
في التليفزيون اكتر من كذا مره اتشهر علي
في مجالات كثيره ان اني بعرف احط ماركتينج
استراتيجي ما تخرجش الميه زي ما بيقولوا
احسن ماركتينج بتطلع من تحت ايدينا لانك
وبعدين
في 2021
حصل ان شويه قانون الضرائب اتغير لشركات
ماركتينج ودي اللي بيشتغل في الديجيتنج
عارف قانون الضرائب عمل فينا ايه هي
النظره اللي هي اي حاجه جديده بتتطبق
فكانت مش مفهومه هو ايه اللي بيحصل حصل
حاجات كتيره قوي كانت بجد ممكن تهدد
الشركه بلس في اول 2022 طبعا الازمه
الاقتصاديه واللي حصل للجنيه المصري
تفتكروا عملنا ايه
قفلنا الشركه عملنا ايه
فتحنا شركه تانيه ليه
لا
هي الحقيقه احنا اشتغلنا وقلنا عملنا اولا
احنا كنا
من الشركات اللي والله والله اليوم 21
مارس اللي حصل ديفال للجنيه احنا كنا من
الشركات اللي زودت الناس قبل ما تروح
بيوتها بنفس القيمه اللي الجنيه قال كل
الناس وصل لهم ايميل ان مرتب بتاعهم هيزيد
في اليوم ده قبل ما يروحوا عشان الناس ما
تروحش زي ما احنا متضايقين كنت انا وشركتي
مضايقين خايفين مش عارفين ايه اللي هيحصل
وكنا قلقانين جدا والحمد لله يا رب قلنا
ان احنا هنزود ناس مرتباتهم وربنا يكرمنا
ده اللي حصل بدانا نشتغل مع شركات بره مصر
بقينا بنشتغل مع شركات اكتر بقينا بننفذ
حاجات اكبر بقينا بنسعى بشكل كبير قوي
وربنا كرمنا جدا مقفلناش الشركه لسه بنمشي
مش عايزه اقول لا
بنمشي في الحياه كويبس انزل
عملت في 20 22 السنه دي اكتر حاجه انا
بحبها
عملت
للستات اللي فوق سن التلاتين انا بدات
حياتي كلها بعد سن 30 وبتجيلي ناس كتير
اوي في النادي وامهات صحاب ولادي في
النادي وفي كل مكان بروح عبير انا نفسي
اشتغل عبير قولي لي هو ينفع تشغليه قولي
لي اعمل ايه طب اتدرب ازاي طب انا بصي
ممكن قلت
الحقيقه فكرت
من شهر 2 اللي فات
ان نعمل ستار ده ان احنا نساعد كل ست
اتجوزت وقعدت في البيت
وعدها ثلاث اربع خمس سنين ما بقتش فراش
جراد بقت بعيده عن السوق الست دي ما بقتش
بصراحه يعني بنفس الفرص اللي بتجيلها مش
نفس الفرص اي حد جراند ان هو بيحضر ايفانس
يحضر جيرز يبقى عارف الدنيا فيها ايه يبقى
عارف اصلا الورك عامله ازاي هي بعيده قوي
بس هي نفسها ترجع ولادها بقوم في المدرسه
او زهقت او عايزه اتعلم او حتى النظام
الاقتصادي او يعني الوضع الاقتصادي للبلد
فيه هي عايزه تساهم في البيت
من اكتر الجمل اللي سمعتها على الاستارت
ده انه طوق مجاليهم والحمد لله هو لقى
قبول من مجموعه من الانفاس
والحمد لله
بنكبر فيه
ونازلين فيه اكتر من صامت وان شاء الله
هتسمعوا عنه قريب قوي
اقول لكم ان ايضا
[موسيقى]
ثانكيو ثانكيو
[تصفيق]